So in a recent video we
did on radical openness,
we talked about the
importance of technology
as something that creates new
possibilities in the world.
Technology acts as a kind
of cognitive scaffolding
that extends the
reach of our agency.
It extends our
possibilities outwards,
beyond the biological
skin tissue.
And it also unearths
new modalities
of artistry, new languages
of human subjectivity.
New ways to narrate human
becoming, the becoming
of the imagination, of the
subjective perspective.
Imagine how
impoverished the world
would have been if we didn't
have the technology of oil
painting in time for Van
Gogh's genius to unfurl,
or how impoverished the world
would have been if we didn't
have the musical instrument
technology in time
for Beethoven's genius,
Beethoven's voice
to be burst through that prism.
New technologies, new
modalities, new possibilities.